xbox's 2021 lineup was full of bangers
it was packed with triple a hits as well
as smaller scale games are plenty
helping to keep the xbox library feeling
fresh and diverse with all that in mind
here are gamespot's 5 best console
exclusives for the xbox in 2021
343 industries had failed to step out of
bungie's shadow for more than a decade
despite 343's best efforts with the
reclaimer sagas beginning in halo 4 and
the two-person perspective campaign and
esports emphasis of halo 5 guardians but
with halo infinite all the pieces
finally fell into place and the extra
year of development time seems to have
been exactly what the game needed the
campaign set in an open world for the
first time manages to introduce player
choice and experimentation to the series
without sacrificing the traditional
linear missions of the earlier games
it also gives us a new side to the
master chief that feels earned and it
addresses past games plot points while
remaining welcoming to newcomers in our
halo infinite campaign review jordan
remay said it was the best halo campaign
in years and an excellent evolution of
what halo can be and the multiplayer oh
the glorious multiplayer yes it has some
progression issues to iron out but halo
infinite's competitive multiplayer is
the best the series has been since halo
3. the map design weapons and special
items all feel like they were designed
with each other in mind creating matches
where something goofy or exhilarating is
bound to happen
even if it's you dying it's often wild
enough to still be entertaining
now available on xbox series x and s
after previously being a pc exclusive
microsoft flight simulator is one of the
most stunning technical achievements
ever video game or otherwise letting you
pilot a wide variety of planes across
the entire planet and with many of the
landmarks airports and other buildings
bespoke rather than computer generated
via map data the game allows you to both
learn the basics of piloting a plane
while also going on a virtual vacation
fly to paris and then take a detour to
berlin then jet down to south america
your only limit is your imagination and
optional hardware lets you use a flight
yoke so you can feel like you're in the
cockpit in our microsoft flight
simulator review edmund tran said
microsoft flight simulator is a dense
carefully crafted tool that's more about
authentically replicating an experience
than being a game in many ways which
makes translating it to a gaming device
a difficult task but if you're able to
get past the overwhelming menus at first
there are many ways to jump in and have
a great time in flight simulator
forza horizon 5's general lack of major
end-of-year buzz comes down to an
amusing problem for developer playground
games we all knew it was going to be
great the studio which has thus far
released only forza horizon games
doesn't have a dud yet in its catalogue
and that streak continues in forza
horizon 5 but failing to acknowledge
just how good it is would be a mistake
because we can't take racing games like
this for granted despite being set in a
humongous area forza horizon 5's mexico
is more diverse than ever before with
nearly a dozen different biomes they
look nothing short of breathtaking on
the xbox series x2 but it's not just a
technical showcase forza horizon 5
continues the series knack for emergent
gameplay often sending you to do fun
side activities on the way to the race
you planned on doing it never feels like
wasted time however because these
moments are what make forza horizon 5 so
satisfying nothing feels like filler
getting sidetracked is the whole point
in gamespot's forza horizon 5 review
alessandro barbosa called it another
meaningful evolution of the series as
opposed to a reinvention but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's a case of
more of the same
available on xbox one and xbox series x
and s fire game pass the artful escape
features one of the most striking art
styles of any game released in 2021
looking like a lisa frank activity book
that has gained sentience but the game's
main character francis is anything but
as bold and confident as the artful
escapes stylish visuals would imply
instead he seems unsure of himself and
of the persona he wants to embody on
stage through a fantastical journey he
routinely cranks out tunes on his guitar
the artful escape blends genres together
which can make it a tough sell for those
looking to play a game based on other
similar titles and as andrew king said
in our artful escape review it's largely
successful at stripping out anything
that would distract from its masterful
presentation that presentation and the
story it's telling are more vital to the
artful escape than traditional game
elements such as challenge or mechanical
complexity but it also keeps the game's
tone and style consistent
another one of the smaller scale but no
less important xbox console exclusives
released in 2021 sable uses the
traditional open world concept and takes
it in a completely different direction
than most aaa games rather than throw a
million waypoints at you the gorgeous
exploration game allows you to explore
at your own pace only giving you slight
hints and direction so you don't get
completely lost it's a refreshing
approach compared to games that seem to
forget what makes open world games so
enthralling a sense of discovery and
self-pacing though there is some clear
influence from other open-world games
especially zelda breath of the wild
sable's approach to design and pacing
feel unique in 2021. in our sable review
richard wakeling called it methodical
introspective comforting and fully
deserving of your time
so there you have it gamespot's top 5
xbox console exclusives of 2021 we'll be
revealing our top 5 playstation switch
and pc games so make sure you hit that
subscribe button so you can catch up on
the best games of the year speaking of
we also have a deep dive into why death
loop is our game of the year thanks for
watching
[Music]
you